[Musik]
nachrichten des tages
mit nie frisieren guten abend ihnen
allen tennis und fußball der frauen
später mit kristin otto toller sport
genannt und das sind einige unserer
themen an diesem samstag
unterwegs in einem paradies auf abruf
der steigende meeresspiegel bedroht
palau die außenministerin fordert
globale solidarität
das gas und die angst vor dem winter
wirtschaftsminister habeck fürchtet eine
zerreißprobe wenn der staat erdgas zu
teilen muss
und triumph in wimbledon jelen arriva
kino aus kasachstan gewinnt gegen
monster boer für beide war es das erste
finale in einem grand slam turnier
zwei frauen ziele zwei krisen auf bali
beim g20 treffen der außenminister übte
annalena baerbock scharfer kritik an
russlands angriffskrieg im südseestaat
palau machte sie dann auf die sehr
starken auswirkungen des klimawandels
aufmerksam
vergangene nacht reiste die
außenministerin von bali aus dorthin der
inselstaat liegt im pazifik und besteht
aus bis zu 500 inseln wegen des
steigenden meeresspiegels könnten sie
bald überschwemmt werden angesichts
dieser bedrohung sprach baerbock vor ort
von einem klima notstand und forderte
schnelles handeln andreas künast hat die
außenministerin begleitet die meisten
menschen auf palau wohnen an den küsten
die meisten küsten auf palau sind
bedroht am tag drei ihrer asien reise
steht deutschlands außenministerin auf
einem stück land im pazifik und palaus
küsten menschen schildern ihr problem
wie sie sehen steigt der wasserspiegel
wirklich unkontrollierbar und wir können
nur alle die unsere partner sind fragen
wie sie uns helfen können
how can i help us es kommen nur selten
westliche politiker nach palau die
kleine republik hat das gefühl nicht
gehört zu werden berbalk dankt den
19.000 einwohnern für ihre dringenden
warnungen aber
ich muss zugeben dass unsere
internationale reaktion unzureichend war
unsere unterstützung zu begrenzt
die frage ob eine grüne außenministerin
im namen des klimawandels um die halbe
welt fliegen darf beantwortet bernburg
mit jahr weil manche dinge so brutal
sind dass man sie mit eigenen augen
sehen muss
welche sich durch werbung nutzt ihr amt
nutzt alle möglichkeiten die das
auswärtige amt bietet um ihre
schwerpunkte zu setzen
zugunsten einer für deutschland neuen
entschiedeneren klimapolitik aber auch
zugunsten von bernburg die nächste und
letzte station von bernburgs asienreise
antrittsbesuch in japan
aus aller welt kommen
beileidsbekundungen nachdem gestern in
japan der frühere ministerpräsident abel
ermordet wurde der papst kondoliert
seiner familie halbmast am weißen haus
und auch in indien trauer um aber vor
dem krankenhaus in dem der ex premier
seinen schussverletzungen erlegen war
bildeten sich lange schlangen trotz des
anschlags hält japan an der morgigen
oberhauswahl fest obwohl es strikte
waffengesetz im land gibt wird jetzt
diskutiert politiker besser zu schützen
im sommer an den winter denken macht man
äußerst selten aber weil ein gasstopp
aus moskau droht nehmen sorgen vor einer
sich weiter zuspitzenden energiekrise zu
der mieterbund fürchtet eine notlage für
millionen mieter
wirtschaftsminister habeck warnt vor
einer zerreißprobe und der kanzler sagt
dass das thema energiesicherheit
deutschland noch auf jahre beschäftigen
wird mehr von patricia wiedemeier
noch hat die wartung von nord stream 1
nicht begonnen noch ist nicht sicher
dass danach der gashand zu bleibt doch
schon gibt es täglich warnungen düstere
prognosen von jahren der in der die
unsicherheit spricht der kanzler in
einer videobotschaft des kanzleramt in
diesen tagen beschäftigt und die
sicherheit unserer energieversorgung sie
wird es noch die nächsten wochen monate
und jahre wir haben jetzt viele
entscheidungen getroffen die dazu
beitragen sollen dass wir uns
vorbereiten auf mangel lagen etwa wenn
es um gast geht wir bei und pipelines
flüssiggasterminals wir sorgen dafür
dass ein gespeichert wird in unsere
gasspeicher und wir sorgen dafür dass
jetzt kohlekraftwerke genutzt werden
damit wir gas sparen deutlicher wird der
wirtschaftsminister der in einem
radiointerview über den krisenfall
spricht wenn der staat die zuteilung von
gas steuern müsste zitat das ist ein
politisches alptraum szenario und da
mache ich mir auch keine illusion was
dann an debatten passieren wird auch
über mein ministerium über meine person
das wird deutschland vor einer
zerreißprobe stellen die wir so lange
nicht hatten die jetzige aber auch die
vorherige regierung habe viel zu wenig
getan für den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien kritisiert die opposition und
fordert
wir brauchen einen preis decke wir
brauchen ein verbot von strom und gas
sperren damit niemanden der strom und
gas abgestellt wird weil er oder sie die
rechnung nicht bezahlen kann die
gaspreise gehen durch die decke eine
über gewinn steuer fordert die linke
weitere entlastungen der
wirtschaftsminister der kanzler
verspricht dass deutschland sich mit
hochdruck auf eine krise bei der
energieversorgung vorbereitet
viele von uns empfinden die preise für
das tägliche leben ja schon jetzt als
viel zu hoch 7,6 prozent hat das
statistische bundesamt für juni
berechnet von einer solchen zahl können
die menschen in der türkei nur träumen
dort nähert sich der preisanstieg der 80
prozent marke aus istanbul berichtet
stefan schlosser
sie leben von heute auf morgen einen
plan für übermorgen haben sie nicht sagt
einen schock sie arbeitet als köchin in
einem kleinen restaurant früher haben
sie fünf kilo gemüse eingekauft jetzt
bekommen sie für das gleiche geld nur
noch zwei kilo
wir machen jeden morgen mit der sorge
auch was denn heute wieder teurer
geworden ist und was wir heute auf der
karte präsentieren können der gang zum
supermarkt ist eine regelrechte tortur
inzwischen
alles ist so teuer geworden energie
mieten lebensmittel umfasst 79 prozent
sind die preise gegenüber dem vorjahr
gestiegen die regierung setzt alles auf
wachstum und beschäftigung inflation ist
zweitrangig vor der not der menschen
verschließt der präsident die augen
die kaufkraft unserer bürger ist
aufgrund der hohen inflation um einiges
gefallen aber wir haben niemand ohne
arbeit zurückgelassen verhungern oder im
regen stehen lassen
worte die für viele wie hohenklingen
über 30 prozent aller beschäftigten in
der türkei müssen mit dem mindestlohn
über die runden kommen der wurde gerade
angehoben auf rund 5.500 lehrer 310 euro
es hat nichts gebracht denn gleich
danach sind die preise für die güter
auch gestiegen egal wohin du schaust
alles ist wieder teurer geworden das
reicht hinten und vorne nicht
und experten gehen davon aus dass die
preise noch weiter steigen werden
düstere aussichten auch für alten schule
wie lange sich das restaurant noch
halten kann sie weiß es nicht
seit tagen war spekuliert worden jetzt
ist es offiziell der botschafter der
ukraine in deutschland wenig muss gehen
einen entsprechenden erlass hat das
präsidialamt in kiew am nachmittag
veröffentlicht auch mehrere andere
botschafter werden abberufen mendig war
zuletzt wegen äußerungen über einen
ukrainischen nationalisten in die kritik
geraten die deutsche regierung hatte er
wiederholt scharf kritisiert unter
anderem wegen zögerlicher
waffenlieferungen schauen wir nun aufs
kriegsgeschehen in der ukraine dort
versucht die russische armee weiter in
die region donetsk vorzudringen der
ukrainische generalstab berichtet von
massiven angriffen auch in anderen
teilen des landes wie hier in kharkiv
die armee veröffentlichte bilder die
zerstörte russische panzer zeigen sollen
aber auch das russische militär meldet
man habe ein lager mit haubitzen aus den
usa getroffen dutzende ukrainische
soldaten seien getötet worden
belarus steht ja seit kriegsbeginn an
der seite russlands die menschen im
norden der ukraine fürchten dass sich
belarus auch militärisch in den krieg
einschaltet vor einer woche schon hat
der präsident lukaschenko der ukraine
vorgeworfen raketen auf sein land
gefeuert zu haben dara hassanzadeh hat
das ukrainische dorf circa besucht es
liegt nahe der rund 1000 kilometer
langen grenze zu belarus wir fahren zur
belle russischen grenzer dort begann die
russische invasion und noch heute sind
circa 30.000 bälle russische soldaten
grenznah stationiert am verkehrskreisel
verkauft lena ihrem wald gesammelten
blaubeeren die aggressive tonlage der
letzten tage aus belarus ist ihr nicht
entgangen
wir warten was kommen wird unsere keller
sind vorbereitet
mit jedem zurückgelegten kilometer nimmt
der verkehr ab das handynetz ist
abgeschaltet am ende dieser straße
beginnt das militärische sperrgebiet
kurz vor der grenze zur belarus
ca das letzte frei zugängliche dorf ein
krieg war für die einwohner und denkbar
gewesen brüder völker war man doch
jetzt trauen sie selbst belarus eine
invasion zu
ich weiß es nicht aber
ich persönlich denke sie werden wieder
von belarus kommen das letzte mal kamen
die russen über diese straße und es
könnte wieder reinigen version geben
valentina zieht allein zwei kinder groß
wie fast alle im dorf hat auch sie
gehört dass präsident zu lentzke nicht
mit einem bälle russischen einmarsch
rechner sie hörte aber auch dass er
sagte man sei vorbereitet
heute sah ich eine drohne sehr tief
fliegen ich weiß nicht ob es eine
russische war oder eine ukrainische
im dorf circa leben sie unter einem gang
lässt schwert aber unter einem das
bereits einmal auf sie herab gefahren
ist
in sri lanka ist ministerpräsident
wickremesinghe nach gewaltsamen
protesten zurückgetreten und auch der
präsident hat seinen rücktritt
angekündigt demonstranten waren in den
präsidentenpalast eingedrungen und
hatten aus wut über die massive
wirtschaftskrise den rücktritt der
regierung und des präsidenten verlangt
die polizei hatte vergeblich versucht
mit wasserwerfern absperrungen und
tränengas dem protestzug aufzuhalten der
inselstaat südlich von indien ist hoch
verschuldet und kann kaum noch güter
importieren jetzt
nach deutschland und zu corinna
situation da steigen die zahlen und es
gibt einen hohen krankenstand unter
mitarbeitern und das belastet viele
intensivstationen betroffen gut die
hälfte der über 700 stationen sagt der
präsident der intensiv und
notfallmedizin am markt der funke
mediengruppe aktuell stünden fast 2.000
betten weniger zur verfügung als
vergangenes jahr zwar sei die versorgung
von notfallpatienten überall gesichert
aber zahlreiche operationen müssten
schon verschoben werden so marx alle
zahlen alle daten und fakten zu der
aktuellen für kone variante und anderen
finden sie bei uns online auf zdf heute
und in unserer app
in bayreuth hat es einen mutmaßlich
rechtsextremen angriff auf einen
lokalpolitiker gegeben ein mann soll den
spd-politiker halil tasten erst
rassistisch beleidigt und ihm dann ins
gesicht geschlagen haben die polizei hat
inzwischen einen 35-jährigen
tatverdächtigen festgenommen
fünf frauen sind beim sommerfest der spd
bundestagsfraktion mitte der woche opfer
einer attacke mit ko-tropfen geworden
die berliner kriminalpolizei ermittelt
jetzt wegen gefährlicher
körperverletzung auch bundeskanzler
scholz war unter den gästen
der kurznachrichtendienst twitter will
tesla gründer maske jetzt gerichtlich
zwingen das unternehmen zum vereinbarten
preis von 44 milliarden dollar zu kaufen
kurz vorher hatte maske die übernahme
abgesagt begründung twitter habe die
zahl gefälschter nutzerkonten zu niedrig
angegeben jetzt droht ein jahrelanger
rechtsstreit twitter und maske hatten
eine strafe von einer milliarde dollar
vereinbart falls eine partei vom vertrag
zurücktritt
für techno fans war das heute ein guter
tag als save the planet ist die berliner
love parade an ihren ursprung
zurückgekehrt zur jahrtausendwende war
sie ja die größte open air disco des
planeten und lockte raver aus aller welt
nach berlin später zieht sie um ins
ruhrgebiet 2010 in duisburg die
katastrophe
21 menschen sterben bei einer
massenpanik und es bedeutet das aus
heute also der comeback oder das
comeback in berlin und darüber sebastian
kowski
der wettergott scheint kein raver zu
sein aber das war den fast 50.000 techno
jünger die heute in berlin eine art
loveparade wie bei will feierten egal
unter dem neuen namen ray the planet
wollten sie noch einmal das gefühl der
90er aufleben lassen natürlich mit 120
beats pro minute
gerade in diesen schlimmen zeiten wir
haben ja zwei jahre und dadurch viel
testing gehört und so weiter wir wollen
wieder gemeinsam friedlich zeigen wie
wir uns unsere welt borschemich als
musik familie together ecken also
endlich wieder als techno familie
zusammen kommen das war das motto unter
dem die 18 musikwagen mit ihren
donnernden techno beats vom
kurfürstendamm bis zur siegessäule zogen
und nicht wenige techno veteranen waren
schon in den 90ern dabei und feierten
jetzt mit ihren kindern eine art familie
keiner bringe
einfach die gedanken ganz ausschalten
kannst du einfach nur da sein spaß am
jungen alt alle sind dabei bisschen
verrückt aber alle quasi
am ende lockten die raver die sonne doch
noch raus und feierten zwischen
siegessäule und brandenburgertor die
auferstehung eines berliner techno
mythos
hört nie auf so wir sind jetzt beim
sport und bei der frauenfußball-wm
wahnsinns auftakt absolut so kann es
doch wirklich weitergehen begeisterung
leidenschaft spielfreude der auftakt in
die endrunde verlief für das deutsche
team in london einfach perfekt 4 0 gegen
dänemark der trainingsfreien tag danach
für die startelf wahrlich verdient
nicht allzu viele versammelt heute auf
dem trainingsplatz umso lebendiger ging
es gestern abend in rentfort communitys
die um zu das ganze team glückselig nach
einem alle erwartungen übertreffenden
turnierstart ich denke an heute ein
wahnsinnsspiel gemacht als mannschaft
eine wahl eine super team performance
und der 14 0 zum auftakt das einfach
überragend und ich bin stolz auf die
ganze mannschaft völlig zu recht denn
nach dem führungstreffer durch die
überragende lina magull gibt es keine
zweifel mehr diese deutsche mannschaft
beherrscht dänemark fast nach belieben
weitere treffer durch lehrer schüler
lena ladwein und die nach krone
infektion zurückgekehrte kapitän in
alexandra popp sorgen für eine mehr als
gelungene revanche für die
viertelfinal-niederlage gegen die scania
bei der letzten em
einen guten lauf haben auch die
deutschen hockeyspielerinnen sie stehen
bei ihrer weltmeisterschaft im
viertelfinale das team von valentin
altenburg setzte sich in amsterdam im
ersten ko-spiel gegen die
südafrikanerinnen mit 1 0 durch
torschützen nico lorenz am dienstag geht
es weiter dann gegen neuseeland
als erster spielerin aus kasachstan hat
jänner china das wichtigste
tennisturnier der welt in wimbledon
gewonnen sie besiegte im duell der
beiden grand slam final neulinge und
chauffeur aus tunesien in drei sätzen
jeder narr über china scheint die
sensation nach dem verwandelten
matchball kaum fassen zu können
gewürdigt wird er erleichtert nach ihrem
erfolg über die klar favorisierte
weltranglisten zweite und sogar aus
tunesien nach verlorenem ersten satz
kann die ein meter 84 große und
ausgesprochen starke aufschlägerin das
match in den beiden folgenden durchgänge
für sich entscheiden und uns mit ihren
großen traum vom ersten arabischen und
afrikanischen grand-slam-titel
enttäuscht aufgeben herzogin kate
überreich der 23 jährigen siegerin die
geschichts trächtige trophäe und
kasachstan das land für das die
gebürtige russin seit vier jahren
startet wird seinen neuen superstar mit
allen staatlichen ehren feier
mit dem zweiten tages drehung für baut
van aart endete die achte etappe der
tour de france beim abstecher in die
schweiz hatte der belgier ganz in grün
nach knapp 190 kilometer oberhalb des
genfersees in lusan den stärksten
schlusswort weiter in gelb der slowene
toccata der dritter wurde und morgen
dann geht es ab in die alpen vier berge
was für kletterer das ist alles an
strikt dankeschön christin beim wetter
im südwesten weiterhin mehr sonne sonst
mehr wolken und vereinzelt schauer
details gleich mit denn terry ich
empfehle ihnen auf jeden fall um 22.45
bis heute journal mit marietta slomka
das war es von uns genießen sie den
samstagabend bis morgen wenn sie mögen
[Musik]
stammte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter noch erreicht uns immer noch aus
nördlichen richtungen relativ kühle luft
und einige chancen auch dabei in der
nacht und morgen im tagesverlauf aber
dieses hoch hier setzt sich im laufe der
woche weiter durch und dann wird die
heiße luft von spanien über frankreich
bis nach deutschland angezapft in der
nacht also die besagten schauer im süden
zum teil auch dichter bewölkt nach osten
regnet es etwas und auch an der ostsee
richtung nordsee kräftiger nordwestwind
und das teils mit stürmischen böen das
bei tiefsten temperaturen im
einstelligen bereich zb im vogtland bei
neun grad 8 grad im hessischen bergland
oder richtung eifel bei neun grad häufig
aber temperaturen knapp über der zehn
grad marke am mildesten noch im
südwesten bei 15 grad und morgen dann
einzelne schauer im süden und hier und
da etwas regen häufig aber trocken und
vor allem im südwesten dann auch viel
sonne bei höchsten temperaturen dort bis
25 grad mit 16 grad richtung vogtland ja
die nächsten tage werden allmählich
trockener montag noch etwas regen bei 28
grad im osten und dann 30 am dienstag
und 35 am mittwoch ein schöner abend